after 18 months in the job zakir stama
has delivered his first ever in-person
address to his party as labour leader it
came at the end of a difficult party
conference which saw a major internal
row over the rules for electing the next
leader and
the resignation of his shadow employment
secretary sakira is with us now hello
good morning good morning good morning
how would you rate your speech out of 10
well it's not really for me to rate it
it's for other people to rate it the
impact on the
um people in the conference hall was
pretty profound
i the speech was actually timed at just
over an hour it ended up lasting an hour
and a half because there were so many
standing ovations uh and so much
applause so not just standing ovations
to be honest
there were a few hectares
there but
you know
this week we had massive changes to our
party we had rule changes not the most
interesting outward-facing thing but
hugely important
um we shut the door on anti-semitism
and louise ellman one of our former mps
felt um who left because of
anti-semitism felt able to come back
that was a very emotional moment for us
as a party i mean i always said that i'd
only feel we'd dealt or begun to deal
with anti-semitism when some of the
people who'd left came back so that was
very important we also changed the rules
so the party can face the country and it
was my chance to
explain what that change meant
some people don't like that change and
therefore they shout out at a conference
but the vast majority of those in the
conference were with me
um and
you know the distinction was you either
shout slogans which gets you nowhere or
you change lives by going into
government and i'm in the business of
turning the labour party into a party
that is capable of changing lives by
going into interpol into government yeah
certainly as far as the hecklers was
concerned you said you've said your
message was success not unity how are
you you do need unity though don't you
to move forward
you do need the party behind you and
people are slightly i know
it's always hard to get visa on sat on
sunday what happened was the party voted
for the rule changes so i put those rule
changes forward many people said to me
on saturday and going into sunday both
within the party and many of political
commentators are you sure is this the
right time why are you doing this it is
always the right time to change your
party for the better and to change to
face the country and that was a tough
set of decisions it took strong
leadership i think it would have been
weak to have put that off we made those
decisions
some people when you change direction
and change
course and say winning an election and
going into government is the central
focus um will not be with you but the
party voted them through and the vast
majority of those in the conference hall
yesterday were with me on this and what
about and all labour party members and
supporters should unite in behind our
intention to go into government that's
what the labour party was formed for um
not being in opposition
my i've got
etched in my um you know in my brain
my first year as an mp just arrived i
voted 172 times and i lost 171.
losing votes in parliament then tweeting
about it is not changing the lives of
working people in this country i didn't
come in to parliament um just to tweet
about votes that i'd lost so kate what
are you going to do about those people
that that you can't bring with you
though you know those that are
questioning your parentage is that is
the labour party the modern labour party
not a place for them well look it's a
broad church and there is some people
die in broad church well look there are
it's a broad church and there is
there is something now to unite behind
which is the program we're setting out
a credible program for government we had
rachel reeves with fiscal rules on
monday very serious fiscal rules we set
out proposals on housing on employment
on education we can unite around a
program that is credible
and that will put us in a position to go
into government and i invite all members
and all supporters to unite around that
program because that's what we're for
here is my question is there no place
for them in your party well they'll have
to make their own mind but but but if
you dissent if you don't like
um affordable housing which was what we
unleashed or we unveiled on friday if
you don't like employment rights from
day one including statutory sick pay
which was so desperately needed during
the pandemic if you don't like the idea
that um children should leave school
ready for life ready for work then i
don't really know what you're arguing
against because it seems to me that
certainly working families up and down
the country are desperate for these
changes to be made a decent education
for your children that actually gets
them ready for work and ready for life a
house you couldn't afford and a job that
is near where you live that is high
skilled and high paid and got
if security can't come in behind that
then i honestly don't know what their
dissent is about so what should they do
try a different party well that's
absolutely a matter for them we have put
forward a program around which i think
the vast majority of labour party
members and supporters will unite but i
must always bear in mind that
my focus is on the voters and
particularly on the voters
that didn't vote for us last time and it
is persuade understanding persuading
them that we're a credible party of
government that is my absolutely
fundamental number one priority and do
you do that with a 14 000 word essay and
the longest speech since ed miliband
well look
the that essay that fabian piece
started in this way i spent the summer
going to places where we lost votes and
i did three days it took me ages uh it
was three days and i didn't i didn't
what politicians normally do as you'll
know is um coming on the two o'clock
train uh go to see a business point a
few things in a high-vis jacket do a
piece of camera and get the four o'clock
train home i went for three days to
places like blackpool lips which and i
spoke to people who don't vote labor
anymore and that essay was my on the
train and the journeys i started penning
down what they were telling me so in a
sense it reflected that but you know
does it allow people to take the mickey
out of me for doing you know 14 000 page
um essay of course it does but why do it
then well it was very important for me
to set out um i bet even your mrs didn't
read it she has read it actually she's
the judge of everything
people read it well you say nobody read
it but the fabians say that their
website crashed because so many people
are trying to download it and the fact
we're talking about it
is a good thing okay and the speech an
hour and a half
well
it was planned for an hour the extra
half an hour was because people were
applauding and and giving me standing
ovations that is good
it's a and and some heckling yes
but you know if the only criticism of
the speech it was it was that it was too
long then i'll take that and trim it for
next time okay you'll you'll take the
criticism and move forward um you say
labour is back in business and you want
a serious plan for government didn't you
help write the 2019 manifesto well look
um i did though didn't you well i was
the shadow brexit secretary and
therefore um i was responsible for the
section that dealt with brexit
absolutely um and i
you know i've supported the labour party
at every election in 2019 i supported
lake parties 2017 2015 2010 because like
all labour mps and labour members we we
profoundly believe that a labor
government is better than any
alternative so of course i supported us
in 2019 and every election since i
joined the labour party when i was 16
years old okay now somebody uh reminded
me of a rather unkind quote quite
recently about politics being show
business for ugly people do you have to
be more show business to win
look i i don't
agree with the idea that you've got to
be a
a showman to win
um in politics what i did yesterday or
try to do was to set out
in quite personal terms
um what my dad was like what my mom was
like and how that made me who i am
and why i um have values that
relate to you know work
um and the dignity of work that i got
from my dad care which i got from my mum
who spent you know much of her life um
in
very very ill and in hospital
and equality and security so i set out
why my background
drove me or what my motivations were i
don't think
showman i mean look we've got a showman
as a prime minister now yeah but he's
the prime minister and you're not he
campaign
he campaigned in slogans
and now he's learning that governing and
slogan well he did win the election but
now what's happening let's take the
situation we're in now we've got
um no you go to any petrol station
there's either a massive long queue
or no fuel we've got an energy crisis
we've got food bills going up energy
bills going up
next week universal credit a thousand
cuts a thousand
pounds a year is going to be taken away
from the six million families who are
struggling to make ends meet we've got
a cost of living crisis we have got you
know people desperately worried about
how they're going to get to work next
week
nurses teachers worrying about whether
they're going to have petrol in their
car to get to where they need to be um
we are in you know lurching from crisis
to crisis to crisis yes you can campaign
on slogans you
absolutely can't govern own slogans
except he still is and he's more popular
than you are well
we lost badly in 2019 we had to get our
own house in order that's what we've
done now i think we put ourselves in a
position to put that alternative case to
the country and that's what i intend to
do have i got more work to do yes this
is the beginning of a huge change in our
party huge change in the way that we um
face the country
and now we go on we build on what we've
done uh this week in brighton onward day
in day out week in week out month in
month out year and year out to that next
general election tell me about a tell me
a labour prime minister that wasn't
charismatic
oh well i don't think um uh that's uh
there are many examples and the moment i
name one you'll just say well look
clement actly everybody said well we
have to go that far back oh look
everybody said clement atlee you know
um
would he would he pass the boris johnson
showman test i don't think so
did he change the country profoundly
more profoundly than any prime minister
that's come since yes are we you know
look at the nhs look at what was done
then um but let me give you a let me
give you other examples
um
in wales the welsh
leader first minister is mark drakeford
he has got a very reassuring
honest open transparent style he's not a
showman but when i was in wales with him
campaigning people were coming up to us
in the street and this doesn't happen
all the time
from different parties saying thank you
for the careful way you're leading our
country throughout the world come on
tories don't do anything in wales well i
mean
listen we need to win votes in wales but
what i'm saying you need to win votes in
scotland but what i'm saying to you is
this i suppose is look you know if if
you want a showman if you want a prime
minister where it's priced in
that he's not really honest
um then i think we have to sit back and
ask ourselves what sort of politics are
we really in i think it's far more
important for a political leader to have
honesty integrity and trust and i would
far rather that over showmanship and
pricing in dishonesty so you'd rather do
that and lose
no i'm determined to win i think that
what we need to do to win is to show
that we've changed and to put forward
that credible case as an alternative
government grounded in what i think
people
um
are worried about and concerned about
uppermost in their mind
decent education for our children um
good work near home a health service
social care service that works for
everybody and security by having an
affordable place to live and being able
to feel that because
law and order is under control you can
actually go out in your neighborhood and
and i know that around our kitchen table
although many many issues in the world
to discuss they were the ones that
mattered to us as a working family and i
know that's the same for many many
working families up and down the country
and if you didn't win at the next
election you would obviously step down
look i'm absolutely focused at winning
at the next general election if you
didn't that's what that's what this week
was all about winning at the next
general election and if you didn't you
would step down well look
we are absolutely going for that next
general election i'm fed up with people
saying you can't do it a few months ago
in germany
there were there were predictions about
the outcome of the elections we've just
seen
justified all the the odds this week in
terms of uh where the progressive
parties have have come so i i do not
believe all those people who say with
great certainty this is going to happen
or that's going to happen um events
change politics and we intend to be in a
position
to win that general election how are you
going to win them back in scotland
well in scotland we have got anasawa a
brilliant new leader in scotland who's
absolutely focused
on the union absolutely focused on the
issues that matter to people's lives
health education etc in scotland the snp
said they wanted to be judged on their
record their record when it comes to
health or education or the terrible
situation of drugs deaths
is appalling let's judge them on that
but we have to make the case what did
tony blair have that you haven't
well tony blair has won three elections
so when i've won three elections i will
be good i will i'll accept uh that i
have uh achieved what he achieved he won
three elections he put the labour party
in power for 13 years and changed
millions of lives for the better um and
we should be proud of what we did in
government one of the points i was
making
at one of the points i was making to the
hall um yesterday we need to be proud of
what was there he was charismatic and he
managed to get his points across well
that is what you feel you should be more
tony blair
no i i
ever it's so interesting ever since i
was became labour leader people have
been wanting to tattoo somebody else's
name on my head are you this previous
leader that previous leader the other
previous leader all leaders
um are different
my job is not to try to sort of hug a
leader from the past
but actually to
do the job that the leader laid party
needs to do now which is to get our
party ready to go into that election in
a position to win it and to win it and
so
my job and the job of my team and i say
this to them all the time is we need to
own the next two or three years of our
history and the history of our country
not spend our time discussing what the
the
the good bad and indifferent of what may
have happened um in the past
we're almost out of time sarah everard
former head of um the cps how um did the
police try to rebuild the trust between
young women particularly
given that
a police officer took his handcuffs out
handcuffed her put her in a car drove
her for two hours raped and then
murdered her with his police belt it's
um
as director of public prosecutions i saw
lots of cases i'd obviously rather not
have seen but this case
is almost impossible to describe in
words and
even yesterday when i was addressing our
um conference i was thinking about the
family of sarah everard because i've
been in that situation with other
families so many times when i was
director of public prosecutions and
there are no words that
um can reach what they must be going
through and i think the whole country
feels that
there are
and i know this police officers up and
down the country who are gutted
gutted by this because
they are doing everything they can to
restore confidence in policing
particularly when it comes to violence
against women and girls and this man now
i'm not going to name this man has let
them down so so profoundly and they're
gutted about that because they know how
much harder it is for them now to do the
job uh that they are trying to do
serving their communities
got to change the law this particular
case needs to be looked into how did
this man slip through the net got to
change the law what do you mean we need
a victim's law we've needed a victim's
law for years i was arguing for this
when i was director of public
prosecutions we have codes we have bits
of support nothing in law that people
can actually
use to enforce their rights we need
better provision in relation to violence
against women and girls in law we've
needed it for a very very long time and
if the government were to put up
legislation on violence against women
and girls or victims on the first monday
when we return after these party
conferences we will vote for it
okay um i i do need to let you go but
let's try and end on and up should we um
you're naked you've obviously been a
long way
quite a challenging few days are you
going to relax at the weekend by
watching james bond well
having
um
dragged my wife to brighton uh for the
concert she looks fantastic by the way
she always looks
fantastic but uh whether we'll get to it
this weekend i don't know we've got a 13
year old boy and a 10 year old
girl
and my mission this weekend is to be
dad who's your favorite james bond
i'm going to go for craig are you only
because i know it's going to annoy you
that's true that's true sean connery
surely
probably i couldn't resist okay
okay but you do want a female james bond
in the future i do i think it's been
really well i haven't seen this film yet
no spoiler alert but
you won't be disappointed with this
movie then very good that's all i'm
saying we must get to see it i know
you're not good i'm going to let you go
and
warm regards to your misses thank you
very much indeed thank you very much she
does for the national health service as
well of course thank you